well the next layer in the American
laughing stock of Republicans
controlling the House of Representatives
is happening now not only are
Republicans blocking Democrats Adam
Schiff and Eric swalwell from the house
intelligence panel they have placed
Marjorie Taylor green and Trump's
lunatic doctor Ronnie Jackson on the
coronavirus committee I know I know it
is an absolute pathetic joke now on the
bonus show later today oh the bonus show
where you want to make money yeah
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves is bad exactly we are going
to talk about the first part of what I
just told you Kevin McCarthy blocking
Adam Schiff and Eric swalwell from the
house Intel panel NBC news reports
speaker Kevin McCarthy followed through
on his threat to prevent the two
Democratic lawmakers from keeping their
seats on the intelligence committee
so that's happening let me mention a
different aspect to this which is closer
to the bottom of this article meanwhile
McCarthy named congresswoman Marjorie
Taylor Greene who had been suspended
from social media platforms for
promoting covet disinformation to the
select panel on the coronavirus pandemic
Congressman Ronnie Jackson of Texas a
republican who was Trump's White House
physician also got the nod for the covid
panel Jeffries will now have an
opportunity to appoint Democratic
members to the special panels they also
by the way before we start weighing in
further on this there's also a
weaponization panel what are they
studying themselves no Republicans have
said the new weaponization panel will
examine Republican accusations that the
justice department FBI and other law
enforcement are being weaponized to
investigate conservatives including
Trump they're going to look at the FBI's
search of Mar-A-Lago and other things
okay
um listen
we knew they were going to do this we
knew that they were going to flip
everything on its head up was going to
be down left was going to be right they
were going to investigate Hunter Biden
rather than anybody actually connected
to government today we knew that they
were going to do all of these different
things and look at the reactions from
these folks Ronnie Jackson this is maybe
one of the most dishonest prominent
doctors I mean I can think of some
others actually but Ronnie Jackson's the
guy who has Trump's doctor said Trump
was six feet three inches tall and
weighed 239 pounds listen I'm not about
fat shaming I'm not about whatever I'm
against lying and there is no way in
hell Trump is 6'3 and weighs 239 but
Ronnie Jackson kept up the LIE Ronnie
Jackson tweeting and gleefully
responding to this committee assignment
saying quote I'm proud to announce that
I've been chosen for the select
subcommittee on the coronavirus pandemic
Every Lie told To Us by fauci will be
revealed every lie about the vaccine
will be revealed every lie that was used
to lock you down will be Unearthed we
will reveal the truth
by the way does anybody remember being
locked down I remember when I had to get
takeout for a couple weeks and then sit
outside at restaurants but I have to
tell you I don't remember any lockdowns
Ronnie Jackson going on in a separate
tweet to say be ready fauci the American
people are about to find out everything
you did to this country during covid uh
I think Dr fauci would be glad for the
country to learn about all of the things
he did during covid Marjorie Taylor
green tweeting I am honored to serve on
the select subcommittee on the
coronavirus pandemic it's time to reveal
the truth on the origins of kovid
wow I didn't know she knew anything
about that the authoritarian Democrat
response vaccines and fauci's
n-i-a-i-d involvement in gain of
function research
we are a joke folks we are a joke the
world sees this and wonders what the
hell is wrong with these people remember
this moment where Marjorie Taylor green
was asked by a reporter about how
children died of covid people who
weren't obese died of covid and Marjorie
Taylor green laughed dangerous do you
feel any responsibility for keeping
people in Georgia safe you know there
are children skinny people who have died
of the coronavirus do you feel any
responsibility up
um you know what I think people's
responsibility is their own yeah so she
now will be examining and investigating
what happened during the coronavirus
pandemic it is absolutely Bonkers and
you know this is going to be endless
grandstanding now one thing I want to
ask you about is
when they have these coveted hearings
right
it's something we could cover live but
would my coverage of it legitimize or
legitimate to use a less common version
of the term would my coverage in a sense
legitimize hearings that are completely
unserious in every way the entertainment
value might be high
but these really are people who should
be relegated to you know irrelevant jobs
not anything serious so is it the type
of thing that we should cover live or
not let me know leave a comment and I'm
curious to know your thoughts